a diversity of personalities in a workplace
means a greater balance of strengths and weaknesses,
and this is important for any company.
your organizations need different people
to fulfill different roles,
to fit together
kind of like a puzzle.
to drive your business forward.
you need risk takers
to be able to push you to try new things,
as well as analytical people
who will pay attention to the details
and keep you on the right course.
imagine if your organization was full of people
that were high empathy individuals.
on one hand,
you're great at making people feel value
and creating caring environments,
but what about when you have to give feedback
or manage some of the more difficult
people related decisions
to make your business successful?
that will then be a problem.
so how do we do this?
how do we create a workplace
that consists of different personality types?
it starts off at the hiring process.
there is always a tendency
to hire people that are wired similarly to us
and to also promote people who are like us.
we need to remember that diversity is a good thing.
so we will need to consciously
make the decision to hire people who work differently
to close that gap
in your company.
next, you can also choose to run a personality
exercise with your team.
with this method,
you can share your findings with the current team
and match the task to what they excel in.
it also allows
for you to see if there are any gaps within your team
in terms of personalities
to balance out the group.
so, for example,
if you notice that your group
tends to stay in the big idea
innovation space,
but execution and structure is an issue,
you can then recruit someone
that has more of that trait
or to be part of the team
to balance the work process better.
lastly, is to foster an environment that is optimized
and encourages diverse personalities.
to put in structures of open communication,
safe space to voice out concerns.
with many personalities at play,
there's bound to be conflict and difference in work.
so if there are structures, plans,
processes in place
that allows
introverts to be able to voice out their concerns.
for people with big ideas,
to understand how people who focus
on execution function,
these kinds of things
will foster a mindset amongst the team
that it's okay to work with a diverse group
of personalities.
so with these things in mind,
it's time to start thinking about bringing a diversity
of personalities
to your workplace.